well you may have completely forgotten
in the frenzy of the past week but there
is a Democratic presidential race still
ongoing and there was even a debate last
night a kind of potemkin debate but
still thanks the coronavirus there was
no crowd to play do but fronting or Joe
Biden still did plenty of pandering
Biden vowed to atone for having the
wrong sex and skin color by hiring those
traits rather than merit he will let the
way someone looks decide who he picks
for vice president and the Supreme Court
watch I committed that if I'm elected
president have an opportunity to appoint
someone to the courts will be a point
the first black woman to the courts my
cabinet my administration will look like
the country and I commit that I will in
fact appoint a pick a woman to be vice
president doesn't matter who the person
is or what the person believes or has
done in life I'm gonna pick someone who
looks like this but that's not
patronizing or anything if I didn't stop
there though he also promised that in
his first three months as president
nobody will be deported from this
country not even violent criminals
seriously watch this in the first
hundred days of my administration no one
no one will be deported at all from that
point on the only deportations that will
take place are commissions of felonies
in the United States of America so to be
clear only fellows get deported and
everyone else has a yes well with time
running out for his presidential
campaign Bernie Sanders did nothing
significant to tear down Biden because
he doesn't actually want to win he just
wants to jump around and play
revolutionary he doesn't want to be
President
why does he just say that but I didn't
almost sabotage himself anyway though
when he mistakenly used 2005 era
Democratic lingo which is now banned
because it's racist watch anyone who
shows up to be tested for coronavirus or
gets coronaviruses treated would be held
harmless there are certain things you
can not deport an undocumented alien for
an undocumented person for and that
would be one of them notice the question
of the bottom of this great
how can we make illegal aliens feel safe
enough to get tested for coronavirus
because that that's kind of the number
one concern over on CNN well a whole
year of effort in tens of millions of
dollars and he nearly blew it right
there by using the wrong phrase can he
still make it
author and columnist mark Stein watch
last night's debate and he joins us now
how do you assess this mark I think it's
I think it's terrible this is what it's
like it's it's different if you're one
of the younger candidates if you're like
that skateboarding guy baito
or or if you're like a little Lord
Fauntleroy and you're it's inbred in you
you don't even know what the word alien
is you you don't know what it means but
like they've left themselves it's a
movie if the yeah they've left
themselves with with two cultures who
find it very difficult to walk on these
eggshells and so they they naturally
default to old-time words that you that
you only hear in the recreational lounge
at the seniors home like alien this is
the same guy who was Biden was the same
guy who was telling us that the Trump
was xenophobic for using the word for
word virus you know a virus can't be an
alien a person can't be an alien Joe
Biden completely lost it he said we are
being this virus is attacking us from
abroad
and by that very phrase he's kind of
implying that the virus is is sort of is
foreign in some way so he is in danger
I think of defaulting to sanity which is
always the problem when you've got
people who are old enough to remember
before the lingo had been corrupted
would they remember reality before
Brooklyn became cool no you're you're
you're totally right so did Bernie
Sanders make any headway whatsoever last
night no he he didn't at all he he he
threatened to what's ridiculous about
this whole debate and to go back to
baito and Mayor P you know and you see
them it's like watching ideological
college students and the naivety is
the sweet when your 22:32 47:58
when you got two guys pushing 80 and
nothing they're saying is actually
relevant to the situation the challenges
facing the country it's kind of pathetic
we waste so much time yeah I said ages
ago on this show you know we'll be
talking about transgender bathrooms when
the mullahs new 'kiss the the democrats
will be talking about whether they
should have a Muslim a transgender vice
president when that when the zombie
apocalypse is finally unleashed and
breaks into the debate and devours them
all this was a complete waste of the
time
utterly irrelevant stale worldview of
clapped-out globalism
that's exactly right but the good news
is they'll feel good about themselves as
they do it mark Stein the great mark
Stein thank you for coming thanks a lot
taka